I can announce a new agreement with
Albania and a new approach
six months after he unveiled a Crackdown
on illegal immigration
and claimed a landmark deal with Albania
will lead to Fast Track removals Rishi
sunak's own immigration Minister
conceded the results thus far are
limited off the number of albanians
who've arrived on small boats how many
have been returned under this gold
standard as you put to agreement well I
said hundreds have been returned
what happened to the rest of them well
it's you've got this returns agreement
that means they can just click your
fingers it was relatively early days had
they just disappeared it's relatively
early days but also you only have to
look at the numbers now attempting to
cross what's happened to the others
what's happened to the other albanians
then are they in hotels or do you not
know where they are uh some of them are
being accommodated some have returned
home voluntarily and some may well have
absconded tensions within the
immigration system were in evidence this
week at a London hotel where a protest
broke out after Asylum Seekers were
asked to share four to a room
today it's karma and the home office
argues the accommodation is of a decent
standard the Asylum Seekers we've spoken
to are too scared to come on camera but
they've told us they arrived in the UK
about nine months ago on small boats
they say they're starving and even
though the hotel might look okay from
the outside inside they argue conditions
are terrible
whatever the truth of life here this
does seem to be yet another example of a
struggling system characterized by long
wait and considerable costs the Asylum
system in in general is in a really bad
place and even those who support
refugees think that is a problem the
cost of hotels for people seeking Asylum
is outrageous we agree with that it
shouldn't be anything like uh the cost
that it is to the taxpayer and that is a
direct result of the way in which the
government has mishandled the Asylum
system if the weren't 170 000 people in
this country seeking Asylum some of them
having been waiting here for years to
have their uh claims processed then we
wouldn't be having a conversation about
the use of hotels
tomorrow Richie sunax illegal migration
bill is back in the House of Lords as
elsewhere the government attempts to
strike International agreements to help
fulfill the PM's pledge to stop the
boats Joe Pike Sky News